we begin with the latest on the Travel
chaos for tens of thousands of fires
around the U.S a big part of that misery
is the mountains of luggage piled up at
airports that were hard hit by bad
weather over the past week much of it
belongs to Travelers who were booked on
just one Airline Southwest it has
canceled most of its flights for a week
now and believe it or not more
disruption could be on the horizon
because another busy holiday travel
weekend is on the way Tanya Rivero is at
New York's LaGuardia Airport Tanya good
morning do you have any good news
uh unfortunately Nate I do not Southwest
has canceled more than 2 300 flights
again today of course all of this as
thousands of passengers remain stranded
at airports wondering when they will get
to their final destination
it's the nightmare that keeps soaring to
new heights
thousands of flights across the country
have been scrapped yet again
and the chaos is only growing for
frustrated Travelers on Southwest
Airlines it's just unacceptable more
than 2500 Southwest flights were
canceled Wednesday causing rebooking
Horrors for travelers like Lauren
eidenmueller who just found her luggage
at Chicago's Midway Airport after three
days of searching I mean I was a little
frustrated but I knew like this would
get resolved eventually other airlines
like United American JetBlue and Delta
have managed to keep their daily flight
cancellations low in the double digits
so what exactly went wrong for Southwest
they didn't have the right computer
program to be able to reposition their
Crews or their planes and you have to
move quickly when you've got so many
people that are potentially going to be
displaced it's an operations problem
that comes out of the control of the
airline and they failed CBS News
obtained a document dated December 21st
showing Southwest declared an
operational emergency in Denver over a
high number of ramp agent absences when
a blizzard hit the city Southwest told
employees anyone who called in sick
would need to provide a doctor's note
and would have to work overtime while
Not Unusual in the industry it is a
glimpse into the Staffing struggles
looming over the embattled airline so
the question remains what should
stranded Travelers do next Greenberg
suggests keep all records and receipts
of your purchases involved with your
cancellation like taxis hotels and
toiletries if your bags are lost file a
claim if you have an upcoming Southwest
flight consider buying a refundable
ticket on another airline
Southwest also has new resources on its
website to help impacted Travelers
rebook flights request refunds and
submit information about missing luggage
now in a statement to CBS News Southwest
says rumors about low Staffing are
unfounded and simply untrue adding that
the airline will continue to operate on
a reduced schedule flying at about
one-third of its regular schedule Vlad
all right Tanya thank you very much